Karin is with us in Miami I Karen how
are you I'm fine how are you better than
I deserve what's up recently my mom lost
her job in March and ever since then she
hasn't been able to find work and I've
been really worried for her you know
and along with her not having that much
money she's not really frugal with money
when she actually does get it and I'm
really worried for her because I keep
telling her to get a job you know and
she says she's trying but I feel like
she's kind of unmotivated to try and
work at the moment like I've even given
her business ideas and everything on
think she can do at home maybe but she
really hasn't done anything and I'm not
sure what to do it's difficult to watch
people you love misbehave when they're
hurt when they're hurting she's hurting
obviously what kind of job did she have
before well she worked it like a
hospital she was a mental health
technician making what kind of money
well she's not the main income in her
household so maybe her husband has a job
yes my dad has a job what does he make
oh well he makes I think $100,000 here
maybe okay so she doesn't have a she
didn't have to work to eat yeah okay so
I mean what if she just didn't want to
work well I feel like for her type of
spending that's the problem
she likes to spend money and how old are
you I'm 18 okay all right well there's a
rule that we have discovered in these
cut types of conversations and it's
called the powdered butt syndrome once
someone has powdered your but they don't
really want your opinion about money or
sex and so your mother's not going to
take an eighteen year olds input on her
spending habits you don't have standing
you don't have credibility with her to
have that discussion and that's what
you're discovering am I wrong no you're
not wrong at all
yeah it's just difficult now you know
when you're 58 and she's 96 or something
yeah she may take your input those days
that's a different that's a different
parent-child relationship than an 18-2
whatever and so you know you have to
build some credibility so the only thing
I would tell you to do is a couple
things one is I would not bring up her
spending again unless she brings it up
okay okay - I would tell her lots of
stories about the times that you used to
mess up mom I used to spend and do this
and I used to do this and man when I got
on this budget I got on this humble up
system I got on this plan to get out of
debt I am doing so good and you just
tell your story because your story is
not condemning her it's just it's just
holding up the idea that there's hope
right yeah so tell your story and talk
about how you're winning doing these
things and that changes everything for
you then the second thing you can do is
this is there anyone like maybe your dad
who could sit down and dog with her and
the two of them actually start getting
their act together well I'm actually yes
my dad has talked to her he's actually
one of the people who said we should
call and we both watch your show okay
well this is his job not yours is what
I'm saying and so this would be like our
husband now calling now that's a little
different standing and he puts his arm
around his wife and says look we got a
problem here you're spending like you're
in Congress I mean we got to stop this
there's a problem here and we need to
sit down and work through this issue
together and we've got to put together
some kind of a plan where we have a good
life and we have a good life meaning we
spend some money now and we invest and
save so that we have you know we live
like no one else so later we can live
like no one else but really this is on
your dad to do this it's not on you you
really because you're he's got standing
he's got the position in the household
to have a discussion where as an 18 year
old you don't and it's not just you
obviously are very sharp and you can do
all kinds of things for you I'm not
saying you're not good or you're not
whole or whatever I'm just singing your
mom's eyes you're still that little baby
she used to diaper and it's just hard
for her to take advice from you but not
her husband that's a different thing
and you know he can sit down and if it
wasn't my house I mean sure and I would
just sit down we'd have a discussion ago
this is this is something we're not
doing here and there's a problem and
we've got to work through this and so
he's put up with us a long time and it's
time for him to deal with it now that
that's what I'm saying hey thank you for
the call